Congratulations, you made
it through the lesson.
In this lesson,
you learned about different ways
to help finance your business.
Bootstrapping, loans, and
investors are always to get the money
that you need for your start-up.
By now, you hopefully have a better
understanding of which of these options
is right for you.
In the next lesson, you'll learn how
to get out there and tell your story.
You'll design the pitch that
you'll use to secure investment,
build your team, and
gain users for your start-up.
It's going to be a combination of
everything you've done thus
far as an entrepreneur.
So, when you're ready,
head over to the next lesson, and
you can start building your pitch.
See you there.